aujourd'hui est-ce que vous pouvez me
rappeler la date nous sommes le 30 août
les meilleurs amis
nous sommes le 30 août et le 30 août
c'est une date importante pour TPMP
puisque c'est l'anniversaire de Valérie
Benaim
Valérie
merci d'être là Valérie et
ce soir on va faire un petit jeu pour
votre anniversaire vous allez jouer avec
nous c'est très simple vous avez reçu
énormément de mots sur les réseaux
sociaux
on a sélectionné trois mots vous avez
reçu alors il y a des commentaires qui
vont s'afficher il y en a deux sympas et
un un peu moins sympa ok on va faire
rentrer les trois personnes ce qu'on les
a retrouvé qui ont posté c'est bon vous
allez devoir découvrir qui a posté les
deux mots sympas et qui peut pas vous
blairer ok alors on va d'abord on va
d'abord découvrir le premier mot le
premier mot sans mettre les photos s'il
vous plaît bien entendu si vous ils sont
tellement cons qu'ils peuvent mettre les
photos voilà merci merci et à mon avis
il vient de le faire là le point
d'interrogation là c'est en régime là
j'ai cherché mais un point [ __ ] de
merde alors il y en a un joyeux
anniversaire ma Valérie ça fait
longtemps que nous n'avons pas parlé je
me rappelle de nos échanges par email et
avec tes mots forts sympathiques
profitent de cette belle journée qui
n’est dédiée qu'à toi plein de gros
bisous à très vite alors déjà on voit
que c'est quelqu'un de pas très jeune
parce que par email c'est rare quand
même on voit déjà que la personne voilà
se rapproche de Souleman je te souhaite
pas bon anniversaire en plus tu as pas
l'air en forme
donc là et coucou Valérie bonne journée
d'anniversaire pleine de surprises et de
cadeaux tu le mérites je t'adore femme
couille je savais pas je t'ai pas vu en
maillot cet été qui n'a peur de rien ni
de personne gros bisous on va faire
rentrer les trois personnes qui sont
avec nous ce soir à plus
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être là alors merci Sarah avec
plaisir
[Musique]
tu fais quoi dans la vie je suis bouché
charcutier ou que boucher que boucher
mes cheveux de sur un stage fait de la
boucherie artistique
genre des steaks qui font du trampoline
et on est avec France ça va ma France
oui ça va merci d'être là
ce soir
ce soir c'est l'anniversaire de Valérie
benaïd et trois mots ont été postés donc
on va démarrer par joyeux anniversaire
ma Valérie ça fait longtemps que nous
avons on va parler je me rappelle de nos
échanges par email à ton avis qui a
posté ça Valérie si tu gagnes si tu
trouves les trois qui ont postés Valérie
Benaim tu gagneras un magnifique cadeau
puisque tu gagneras
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on peut pas faire un jeu imaginez
attention genre les 12 coups de midi ici
je me suis trompé c'est Maxime Valérie
Benaim le cookeo part s'en va
alors à votre avis si qui a mis l'autre
mot voilà qui dit bonne journée
d'anniversaire pleine de surprises et de
cadeaux
plein de surprises de cadeaux
qui vous a vu dans la douche
[Rires]
[Musique]
est-ce que excusez-moi vous croyez qu'on
a vraiment le temps je dis non je pense
encore pour France alors France elle
peut pas avoir écrit tout le monde
mais là c'est bien France
[Applaudissements]
oui oui parce que c'est vrai la parcours
extraordinaire et puis
c'est vrai
journaliste elle a été dans pleine de
l'émission etc
j'ai pu surpasser des choses qui sont
difficiles dans ma vie très difficile
parler avec cette personne par mail ou
elle m'a dit que c'était
plein de bonnes choses que j'avais enfin
j'étais quelqu'un de fort avec beaucoup
de volonté et c'est grâce à ces mots
j'ai pas bravo
RTL ou sur sur la célébrité ou domino
Day ou tes parents et tout ça
aux Antilles on appelle ça le genre de
femme que tu es il y a les femmes poteau
mi-temps qui tiennent la famille et qui
tiennent les
rennes elle peut rester deux heures sur
un poteau
alors on a vu Maxime et France vous avez
déjà après il y avait un 3e mot je te
souhaite pas bon anniversaire en plus tu
as pas l'air en forme et c'est bien ça
Sarah forme quand même
aujourd'hui ça va plus tu as eu un
problème avec Valérie Benaim ah non j'ai
jamais le problème juste quand je
regarde les missions je trouve qu'elle
parle beaucoup pour rien dire
[Applaudissements]
c'est
inutile en fait je la trouve pas je
trouve qu'elle sert pas à grand chose
dans les
inutile mais est-ce que tu penses que
ton commentaire est utile
et je veux dire elle a le droit de dire
ce qu'elle pense Sarah moi aussi il y a
plein de gens qui disent que même temps
je dis ce que je pense
que parce que vous tu n'es pas d'accord
avec moi lorsque je dis les choses ou
est-ce que pas forcément je te sens je
sais pas
[Musique]
hypocrite avec les chroniqueurs je sais
pas hypocrite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors est-ce que tu peux lui souhaiter
en chantant pas bon anniversaire Valérie
on l'a regardant merci pas bon
anniversaire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
maintenant je vais me tourner vers les
téléspectateurs
[Rires]
les Chéries
alors les chefs c'est très simple c'est
très simple je vais demander une musique
de suspense
et je vais me tourner vers France Maxime
et Sarah ils vont me donner leur
décision chacun leur tour musique de
suspense bordel de merde
on va jouer maintenant pour savoir si on
offre le cookeo à Valérie Benaim ou pas
et c'est vous
décidé il me faut trois oui ça va
attends tu vas on va on terminera par
toi
France
est-ce que tu es pour offrir le cookeo à
Valérie Benaim
oui
Michel comme ça ça aille dans la lumière
entre dans la lumière ça va comme un
insecte fou
Maxime est-ce que pourquoi Valérie
Benaim mérite le cookeo pour son
anniversaire
moi je dis oui
alors
ça va c'est toi qui décides et Sarah tu
n'es pas obligé de dire oui elle est pas
obligé de dire non en tous les cas de
l'emporte j'aimerais qu'on amène ce
cookeo ici pour que le voit peut-être en
partie
ça va c'est très simple moi je pars
partir avec ça c'est très simple c'est
très simple si tu dis oui Valérie bénéim
gagnera le cookeo si tu dis non tu
repartiras avec moi
tous les trois non pour partir et les
trois avec un cookeo oh là là
il est magnifique bah oui il est
magnifique alors je t'explique
ça ça coûte cher ah ça coûte super cher
alors
la cuisine
aluminium quand même
est-ce que tu es sûr
[Applaudissements]
ça va est-ce que tu es sûr de toi
ça coûte 1000 € s'il vous plaît et les
sénates
sa réponse définitive c'est 1000 euros
c'est magnifique c'est un truc tout le
monde le voit là
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît tu repars avec le cookeo
tu as pris ta décision malheureusement
je vais faire quelque chose que je ne
fais jamais
[Applaudissements]
non pas le cookeo pour toi ce sera le
cookeo je t'offre un week-end où tu veux
avec la personne de ton choix